dans ce qu'il convient d'appeler
''l'affaire du naufrage erika cette
information donnée par nos confrères de
libération selon laquelle la compagnie
shell aurait jugé inacceptable l'état du
pétrolier pour le transport de son
propre fioul
une nouvelle révélation à charge qui met
en cause pour le mois une certaine forme
de laxisme de total fina la société qui
a aussitôt répliqué en rejetant toute
responsabilité sur les autorités
chargées de l'inspection des navires
patrick fandio
c'est un témoignage qui fait des vagues
à la une de libération
le quotidien a interrogé un inspecteur
de la compagnie pétrolière shell un
homme qui affirme qu après une
inspection janvier 99
il a été signalé à l'armateur que les
riquet ne pouvaient transporter de
cargaisons chaînes en clair une sorte de
veto car pour la compagnie anglo
néerlandaise
le pétrolier n'était pas assez sur un
jugement
apparemment partagée par d'autres
compagnies du moins si l'on en croit le
rapport de la commission d' enquête du
ministère des transports
d'après ce document depuis septembre 96
pratiquement aucun des grands groupes
pétroliers n'a frété l'erika seul total
a affrété le navire
quatre fois en 1999 total qui se défend
ce soir d'être la moins exigeante des
compagnies pétrolières le critère
d'affrètement sont exactement les mêmes
que ceux de shell nous faisons partie de
la même organisation qui s'appelle le
cir est si heureux et nous avons les
mêmes critères d'inspection et le même
type d'inspecteurs seulement sur la base
des rapports techniques de leurs
inspecteurs les compagnies pétrolières
tirent des interprétations fort
différente par souci de sécurité
certaines d'entre elles ont adopté
d'autres critères de sélection des
navires il est clair que la décision
d'affréter un navire repose bien sûr sur
son état technique mais aussi sur son
adaptabilité au trafic bien déterminé
que peut avoir telle ou telle compagnie
à ses exigences propres voir la
situation financière de l'affréteur la
commission denquête ledit weyer pour
qu'il y ait peu ou plus d'erika il
faudrait entre autres que les compagnies
pétrolières soit à nouveau propriétaire
des navires qu'elle utilise une
perspective qui a peu de chance de se
réaliser dans un secteur maritime ont
sévi une féroce concurrence